hey guys how's it going so right now we
are heading into petsmart with our dog
maddie jenna behind the camera hello
we're currently on the east coast we've
been visiting our family a lot this year
so we decided that it would be really
fun to do an east coast cribs makeover
for maddie it's a huge thank you to
petsmart for sponsoring this video this
is actually our one-stop go-to for all
of our pets needs so thank you guys so
much for supporting our channel and our
baby boy maddie he is crying in the car
because he wants out he wants to go shop
you ready to go shopping buddy come on
let's go do you want to drink before we
shop no no let's do shopping okay
[Music]
so one of the really cool things about
petsmart is they also have customer
charities and through their adoption
programs if you don't have a pet they
can also help you adopt one maddie maybe
we adopt another pet today
[Music]
okay maddie first thing we're gonna find
we're gonna find you a bed okay
let's go get you a bed
[Music]
look at all these options hey check this
out this one's a little high for you but
look
is that a soft little bed first item
success
one thing that i think he also needs is
a crate we have one at home and he was
crate trained when he was little so now
it's like his little comfort zone see if
this one is good for you look at this
this is a 30 inch folding crate it's by
top paw can you say top paw
i think it should be a good size
buddy
you know what else we need maddie we
need to find a crate pad what do you
think of this mat do you think this is
nice
we gotta find something to store your
treats and your food in this is so cute
he's a very small dog i feel like we
could actually use this though to put
his toys in so if you have a bigger dog
this would be perfect to store their
food in this one is actually also really
cute this is much smaller and my sister
also has a dog so we can put all of
their treats in here time to find you a
food and water bowl okay
let's see this one
test it out
eat
good boy i've also been wanting to get a
little dog camera for him so that we can
watch him when we aren't home
check this out buddy 1080 full hd oh
it's actually wire free which is awesome
ip65 weather resistant what's cool about
this is if you do have a dog that is
outdoor this is weather resistant so
you'll be able to put it outside check
that out
but this will also work for indoor as
well into the car to go
[Music]
so since he already has this harness
let's get him a collar and a leash okay
i absolutely love this one yeah and they
have the matching leash
that's nice that is so nice
we need a little grooming accessories
i might even use this for myself
[Music]
oh man okay so this is actually not for
maddie this is for my sister's dog beau
maddie only likes toy balls when another
dog is playing with it and both of them
are going to lose their minds when they
see this
[Applause]
[Music]
we did it we did it now time to go home
and set up your new crib
[Music]
look at you in your little bed come here
i'm gonna scoop you up like a burrito
there you go
this collar looks so nice on you do you
say thank you petsmart did you know that
petsmart also has curbside pickup and
you can get things same day on doordash
did you know
now you do time to set up
he said can you put some food in that
bowl oh what's that is that yours is
that your toy
[Music]
i love how these just fold down
so like you can really take this
anywhere oh this has two sides we can
decide which way he wants his entryway
door this
is what you use for crate training so
when they're a baby you don't want them
to have too much room to move around or
potty so you can use this divider to
create it off as they get older maddie's
a big boy now so he doesn't need a
divider come here top dog top paw i got
to put this in there buddy i know you'd
like it so much
can i put this in there and then you can
go in there gonna go to your crate
there you go
good boy we trained him when he was
little clearly he hasn't forgotten i
mean would you forget something for a
treat
eat bowl
his little drink bowl here jenna
actually had a really good idea for this
obviously this is too large to use for
food for our dog but for a larger dog
this would be incredible for dry food
but we're going to use this as your
little toy box we'll put your toys in
there
this is already looking great
[Music]
now time to check out the outdoor camera
which we're going to be using indoors
[Music]
well look we got this for you
get it get it get it another one oh so
many
okay these are actually perfect juggling
balls
[Music]
well it seems like beau is also enjoying
his new toys
thank you guys for watching i hope you
guys enjoyed this video i'll put a link
in the description if you want to check
out all of the items that i bought for
maddie from petsmart thank you again
pessimar for sponsoring this video and a
huge thank you to maddie for being a
good sport and bowie you also benefited
from the shopping spree if you guys
haven't already be sure to hit subscribe
and like this video if you enjoyed it
and leave a comment below for me to read
to maddie oh my gosh he also loves his
new bed too this is awesome i'll see you
guys in the next video bye
[Music]